hallo alex wo bist du denn genau ich bin
jetzt im park aber der ist riesig am
adenauer wire
du musst zur roten bank hinterm stadion
da sitzt sie schon warte auf dich mal
sehen ob ich dich finde
bis gleich hallo lena gehst du nicht
mehr ins handy ich erreiche ich schon
die ganze zeit nicht bitte melde dich
mal ich muss unbedingt mit dir reden
ich hatte so einen blöden streit mit mag
und von wegen auslandsschule du musst
unbedingt hier bleiben okay ist gleich
null
der perser gelten als machos so einer
bin ich nicht ach ja ich könnte mich
geschlagen nicht so gut aus mit euch per
seien aber naja es gibt ja die pfälzer
teppiche die perserkatze und die verlauf
wir natürlich das ist gar nicht schlecht
siehste mal da mussten wir wohl alles
beibringen was mich besser wissen
alex wie komme ich zur bank und wo ist
überhaupt dieser komische war
wie hieß der noch adel adenauer war das
ein kleiner see der nach einem
ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin land ist
wichtiger care nach dem krieg ja ja und
war heißt also see naja gut wichtiger
ist mir wo ich ihn finde ganz einfach du
findest ihnen wenn du jetzt noch 30
meter geradeaus gehst du dich nämlich
willkommen
ich habe mich übrigens sehr über deine
nachricht gefreut
was mich halt immer so nervös dann weiß
ich nicht was ich sagen soll ja auch
nicht immer reden